Republican Senator Mitt Romney is not someone
that I go to when I need advice about anything.
He's not someone that I agree with on policy
almost ever, except for maybe some completely
uncontroversial, small things. But he has done
one thing right during the last couple of years,
which is for the most part, he
just tells things as they are,
even when they are about the Republican Party. And
Mitt Romney predicted yesterday that Donald Trump
would easily win the 2024 Republican presidential
nomination if indeed he tries to win it in 2024.
And this coincides exactly with what the polling
has indicated that we've looked at over the last
month, which is that at least for now, and things
can change between now and 2022, between 20,
22 and 2024. But for now, the vast majority
of the Republican Party is behind Donald Trump
and the 2024 nomination is his for the taking, if
indeed he wants it. Mitt Romney said that he is,
quote, sure, that Trump will at least play a
role in the Republican Party in the coming years,
pointing out that he is by far the largest
voice and big impact, a big impact in the party.
And that, quote, I expect he will continue playing
a role. I don't know if he'll run in 2024 or not,
but if he does, I'm pretty sure he will win the
nomination. Romney did point out, as we've been
pointing out, that things can change between now
and 2024, but that for the time being, quote,
I look at the polls and the polls show that among
the names being floated as potential contenders
in 2024, if you put President Trump in there among
Republicans, he wins in a landslide. I think that
that is absolutely and completely correct. And
unless something changes, if Trump wants it,
the nomination is likely to be his in 2024.
Now, what is it that could change? And I think
this is the most important thing to think about.
Well, a couple of different things could change.
Number one, Trump could change things by starting
his own party. And we've talked about this before.
For now, Trump has such a following within
the Republican Party that if he were to say,
I'm leaving the party and starting my own,
64 percent of Republicans say they would
leave with him. Now, I don't believe 64 percent
actually would. I think when it came down to it,
particularly if a year has gone by, if two years
have gone by, there's a serious likelihood that
some of that 64 percent would say, you know, I'm
kind of over Trump, I'm actually going to stay.
But even if it's 20 percent or 30 percent or 40
percent of the Republican Party, that does leave.
If Trump starts his own party, that could spell
absolute and total disaster for the Republican
Party. And it would also mean that the Republican
nominee would not be Trump because Trump would be
the nominee of whatever party has starts that
he starts. That's something that could change.
The other thing that could change is that all
of this energy around Trump, much of it fomented
by his claims for two months after the election,
that Joe Biden stole it and that he actually won
subsequently by continuing to claim and being
supported in his claims by Newsmax and 018 and
to some degree, Fox News, that he has this
strategy or that strategy to try to get the
election back. That generated a lot of excitement
and a lot of interest and a lot of energy.
If that simply dissipates with Trump out of the
spotlight, then you could also see the party going
in a different direction that maybe would not
choose Trump as its 2024 nominee. And then also,
I think that this will sort of be a feedback loop.
But if Trump sort of fades away a little bit over
the next 18 months, it's quite possible that many
of the Trump and elected officials that came to
power only because of their affiliation with Trump
ism. I'm thinking about Marjorie Taylor Greene,
Lauren Bobert, Madison Cawthorn, and there are
others. But those are sort of the big three.
The Trumpy elected officials may get absolutely
destroyed in their 20 22 reelection campaigns.
I already saw some early data and statements out
of Marjorie Taylor Greene's district in Georgia
that suggests it could be a bloodbath for
her in November of twenty 22. It's so long
from now. It's very difficult to say for
sure. We're, you know, 19 months away
or something like that. But if the Trumpy
elected officials get crushed in 2022,
that may kind of continue this decline of Trump
ism within the Republican Party. But Mitt Romney
is completely right. As of right now, Donald
Trump would easily win the Republican nomination.
And, you know, we talk about areas in which
Democrats and Republicans are too similar
and areas in which Democrats and
Republicans couldn't be more different.
Donald Trump never could have won a Democratic
primary in 2016, never would have happened.
The Democratic electorate simply would not be
bamboozled in that way. You can. They say a lot of
things about elected Democrats and a lot of things
about the Democratic electorate, but they would
never fall for someone like Trump. The Republican
electorate not only fell for it in 2016,
they continued to support him in 2020 to
almost the same degree. He ultimately did lose
the presidential election and so far they still
support him. That is a dramatic difference between
the Democratic electorate and the Republican
electorate in terms of what they are capable
of falling for. And at this point, all we can
do is wait. This Sunday, Donald Trump will make
his first public speech since leaving office at
CPAC. We will be covering it live. And I'm curious
to see if and what he says, if anything, about
the 2024 election or even 2022. He is expected
to talk about the his future to some degree within
Republican Party politics. So that's, I believe,
in the 3:00 Eastern hour on Sunday. I'll be live
on YouTube, Twitter and Facebook covering that